right now my body feels like it's
failing me
hey guys abby sharp here now before we
get into today's vlog i want to pop in
here to share a quick disclaimer that i
will be talking about medication
depression anxiety and weight gain so
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey i also want
to tell you about my sponsor bill barr
so this is a very serious video and i'm
going to be talking about some really
raw serious topics so not to diminish
any of that but these bars are often a
really nice little pick-me-up and a
great way to get in my protein even when
i'm not in the mood for much i mean
chocolate always goes down well and
build bars have been a staple for me
because the protein keeps me fuller
longer and they're made with real
chocolate all right let's
have a little pre-vlog snack
you know what let's do double chocolate
i mean go big or go home right
[Music]
super yummy all on its own if i just
need a little something to tide me over
or i love to add it to oats or yogurt
for a more saturating meal or snack so
if you want to check out build bar for
yourself you can use my promo code
abbeysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
i'm so depressed and i'm trying not to
use that term lightly
but that is how i feel right now
as i take my
antidepressant ironically
[Music]
but basically my my family have been
sick
back-to-back viruses for what feels like
months now like legitimate months
overlapping viruses so like our entire
spring season apparently is being just
like cancelled
um and you know i already live a really
lonely life right like i i work from
home alone my only social time is like
daycare drop off and pick up so
i try to pack my weekends like as full
as possible with just like fun things
for our family to do i've just been
cancelling them like all i can do is
cancel them going out for dinner with
friends cancel that having a picnic with
you know with other families cancel that
see my in-laws for like a play date
cancel that and the past two weeks have
been particularly bad because my kids
have been so sick oh got hand foot and
mouth so not only have i been barred
from like seeing my friends at a fear of
like you know giving it to them with
from from one of my kids but now i'm
also essentially separated from my own
family because we've been trying to
separate the kids like man on man or
woman on one man on the other what
anyways yeah i haven't been sleeping in
the same room with my husband i haven't
been having dinner with my husband i
haven't been able to sit with my
youngest because you know he's been on
his duty and i've been taking care of
the eldest it is so
debilitatingly depressing and like a
couple days ago my little one wanted to
like give me a hug when it was like
really really bad and the blisters were
open and inflamed and
i was trying not to touch him because
you know we have certain things that we
were trying to look forward to and avoid
us getting the hand foot and mouth as
well and like it
killed my heart it ripped my heart out
not to be able to like touch and cuddle
and kiss him and let him like lick my
face like he always does um side note he
did scratch me so he was upset about
something and that probably is not good
and i then put alcohol on it so now it's
probably going to get infected
so that's where i'm at today making my
coffee but like the worst part is is
that
tomorrow is my sister-in-law's wedding
and i'm a bridesmaid i'm in the wedding
party and i'm very close with her and
i've been looking forward to this day
for
months for so long and i've literally
lost sleep over me worrying about
something as benign as not sleeping the
night before the wedding because i i
wanted to actually fully enjoy the day
and enjoy the night without worrying
about the clock as i normally do when i
like go out with friends on a friday
night this one was especially special
for me and the past week because i've
been so anxious about the unknown like
are we gonna go are the kids gonna get
better are we gonna get this oh like
what's the happening am i gonna
i yeah my sleep has just gotten
horrendous like it used to be that i'd
do like three two or three good sleeps
bad sleep two or three good sleeps bad
sleep now it's like it's opposite um and
the good sleeps are fewer and far in
between and
i
so my my doctor prescribed me something
called
zopa clone which is an even more heavy
duty sleep drug just kind of as like a
drop dead like well not drop dead that's
not what i mean but like take this and
you'll sleep for these really special
occasions and i took it as a practice
run um last night i didn't work i still
didn't sleep i still couldn't sleep in
this state and to anyone watching like
probably you're thinking what the [ __ ]
is the big deal like
this is just another person's wedding
it's not even your wedding day and i get
that but i had this single day this
particular day this event on my mental
calendar as what i was working towards
in my therapy and medication journey
i've been trying to envision and
manifest this night being a really
enjoyable night and day for me and my
family sorry battery just crapped out at
me um
but anyways i just found out that i'm
not going to be getting ready with the
other bridesmaids and my sister-in-law
in the morning um
you know just as extra precaution to
protect her but
i'm just kind of going to be showing up
at the very end uh for the ceremony and
for a couple pictures there before we
start and then going home for like the
dinner and the party and i told my
friend this and she was like oh well i
mean that's too bad but also like oh i
mean isn't this kind of like a good
thing like you were so anxious about
having to
having to go to this thing and not
sleeping or staying out late or whatever
and i was like yes
even though like there's
pressure off of me i
now feel like a complete
failure and it's just another example of
me just avoiding things because they're
hard even if this one was like kind of
out of my hands so i will not allow
myself to feel relief from this
revelation because it's actually a big
loss for me and now i feel like
stupid and guilty and just like i'm a
bad person for making such a big deal
over something like it's not even my day
it's not about me but here i am feeling
sorry for myself
so last night was my sister-in-law's
wedding but the interesting thing is is
that i came home and it like inhaled a
poke bowl
and i went to bed by like nine o'clock
and i had
the best sleep i've had in months on
very little medication
and only had one drink so it's very
clear to me that
you know
any little event on my calendar this is
not even my wedding but anything on my
calendar
is enough to just keep me up for months
on end and send me into this anxiety
spiral and then once the event is over
suddenly the clouds lift and i can
actually sleep again now i gotta say
that even though i've been trapped
literally inside for the past like what
seems like months with sick kids like
over and over again like a new virus
every week which means all of our plans
are constantly getting cancelled
constant disappointments i've cried a
lot because i feel really lonely and
like i can't do or see anyone i
feel
so happy today happy happy happy happy
happy
the fact that i got a good sleep like a
really good sleep
i feel like a whole new person i don't
think that people understand that not
sleeping well simply exacerbates every
little problem in your life it's really
really really depressing and while i
feel like really good just like having a
good day because i slept really well i
also feel in the back of my mind
stressed that i'm still having these ups
and downs that i why have i not leveled
out now why is everything like such a
big deal that i'm losing sleep for weeks
on end over an event that is
not even necessarily
that significant to my life it's not the
birth of my child it's not my wedding i
was just going to somebody's wedding
why
and it's really no different than the
anxiety i feel when i have like friday
night plans to go out for dinner and
thursday nights i just like do not sleep
because i feel like i have to put so
much pressure on myself to get a good
sleep and feel really rested and good so
that i can enjoy the weekend and not
ruin it for everyone so yeah i'm
starting to feel a little
hopeless and unsure if this anxiety drug
is really gonna cut it
god abby you can't just enjoy
like
a good morning after a good sleep gotta
throw in another debbie downer moment
yep that's me that's my mind so it is
monday and i feel like most mondays are
like a struggle for a lot of people
myself included usually so i'm gonna try
to do something for myself just to like
lift me out of my usual doldrums
and
i guess i'm already off to a good start
because the lord has been listening to
my prayers both of my children are out
of the house
oh he's gone to a music class he's gone
to school the sun is shining it's the
last week of school which always you
know he might not really feel it but
tell me when you guys were in school all
through grade school and high school
that last week of school felt like magic
um so i'm trying to like feel that in
lieu of the fact that my kid doesn't
really understand that what's going on
and that he's not gonna be in the class
after this week um but for myself i
decided i was going to get dressed and i
don't do that a lot i change from my
athleisure wear into more athleisure
wear and throw over a house coat i got
three looks
and that's it so we're not going full
glam but like i'll show you what i mean
so yeah we're trying to embrace the
whole like fake it till you make it
mantra um which i really do think plays
a huge role in one's outlook and mindset
um especially on hard days so i put
jeans on i'm not lying when i say that i
own a lot of jeans and i never wear them
only when i'm like going out on a friday
night which let me tell you happens less
than once a week
so
i'm straightening my hair i had a shower
that's huge i put makeup on i'm gonna
put like a lip color gonna finish the
whole shebang and
eat my breakfast
have my coffee and just set my
intentions for the day that it's gonna
be a good day i gotta say it was a good
day because my kids are here
i love them but like you don't
understand what
a huge relief it feels to know they're
not home sick crying
whining and needing my attention 24 7.
this is goals
let's do the day
okay so because i have a rare
burst of energy today i don't know if
it's the lipstick if it's the sunny
t-shirt the fact that i slept pretty
well last night
or my kids are not home but i have been
living in a [ __ ]
disaster zone and i feel like it's
contributing to my daily stress so i
thought we'd clean things up a bit and
i'm gonna take you with me
[Music]
i can barely move in here so
it's time we tidy some things up now
it's time to put away
everything that we took out
this
is gonna go in the garage because it's
stuff i've collected for my
sister-in-law because she's got a baby
coming and i don't need these baby books
anymore and i definitely don't need the
nursing bras
so
she can have those little
gifts
these are little things i bought for her
for bebe so i will keep those until
he arrives this
is another little giftoid
i'll pop it over here
i recently went through all my books in
here to figure out which ones i don't
need anymore a lot of cookbooks and
stuff i have to show you guys something
because this is embarrassing
this
i don't like to waste things or throw
them out but i also don't really want
anybody else to read this so i'm not
sure what to do with that oh my god i
have another one
uh
200 under 200 calories that's the
selling feature to eat a meal with less
than 200 calories that is the fact that
i have book marks in here
says a lot and again i'm like ugh
do i let this out into the wild i mean i
don't like to waste things i know it
might be somewhat useful for someone but
i want to just like write little
little notes everywhere being like add
an extra serving put some olive oil on
that
add some protein
add some carbs like people need a little
more direction
and they don't need to cook themselves
thin
other books i'm getting rid of the un
diet diet because let me tell you
it's a diet i got given this one for
free so i don't need the gluten free
healthy lifestyle recipes
nor do i need the detox recipes
don't need those
no one does
because their body
just
does it
and
this is a beautiful book but it's just
like a little too health for me i don't
want to i don't need diy juicing uh
recipes to be honest my kids aren't
going to eat this so i'm not going to
make it all right yeah i want to get all
these out of my
office
i might have to make a few trips i need
the the
hair basket that's essential
probably don't need oh
the dry race
what probably don't need like my
keratosis polaris
then skin cream in there
i guess we'll keep this
deodorant for emergencies in my office
when i'm sweating profusely in an
interview yeah not a bad idea and a few
other hair clips accessories
a rogue mask why would i need a mask in
my office i don't know i don't another
hair brush probably don't need two hair
brushes
i'm really bad at like making piles and
then moving those piles to other places
for piles but i'm gonna try to stop that
right here right now and do a thorough
job all the things that don't belong
a million coffee cups
bowls
half consumed san pellegrino's
i will finish that
i told you
i told you i would
don't need that
this i will keep
problem with like
everything i buy is that usually it's
like
and then it doesn't really work that
well and or i lose the specific charger
i need to make it work and then it just
basically becomes garbage and i'm just
not really good at being proactive to
fix things the proper way so i have no
idea what most this does okay now it's
time to tackle the
drawers which is a beast in itself
passports and old passports
checkbooks
i guess yeah
business
like who writes checks anymore i don't
know i don't the lipstick i was looking
for
stamps very important
you always need stamps oh my gosh this
is so funny i had a 90s themed 30th
birthday when i was like i don't know
six months pregnant and naturally i was
a baby one more time i was britney wow
that's unfortunate
here i am with my big baby belly i had
went out and bought all of the 90s candy
that i could possibly find like searched
high and low dunkaroos fruit by the foot
what else did we have oh like sour um
war war warheads those were a must we
ate a lot of warheads that night oh good
times oh and popeyes those like
cigarettes terrible like how did that
fly but they were really tasty so
ah and speaking of which
who remembers diet debbie it's me debbie
that's me that's die debbie it's me
debbie in cartoon forum my my friend is
our amazing um
uh illustrator so
she came
prepared
she brought it yeah a bunch of
a million gift cards which will never
get used
oh my gosh this is my old old old
business card
okay these are two old business cards
og business card
look at that when i was like rocking the
retro style
and
this was like the next phase
when i was like still kind of retro but
like a little
less retro i guess i don't know it's all
pretty bad to me
new card
what do you think
very nice
so i think it's safe to say that all
these business cards can go i don't even
know the last time i gave out a business
card it's been years because now you
just say follow me on instagram
um
nobody gives out business cards
maybe my kid and i can do some crafts
with that so
we don't waste them that might be a fun
activity
cut around the mama he's like he'll
probably be like uh ma who is that and
i'll be like it was me in simpler times
all right
oh i found another one
okay so this was like at least this
might have been like my
my last business card before i aborted
all business cards and then it was just
like we don't need business cards
anymore right my phone number so that
was one side
simple yep
and
that's me that's me that was when i shot
my cookbook and i still really love this
photo of me super cute eating cake
okay
okay let's finish up this job okay so
i'm feeling
much
much
better about this
like i've got it all organized
i've got branded stuff in that bin i've
got all my
filming gear here
and out of the way i feel
good
now
did i just relocate the mess
yes
yes i did but at least it's out of my
space and as a result i feel like i can
work a little bit better
so
let's do it
happy friday everyone um it's friday
right now while i'm filming it's
probably not friday while you're
watching but it might be
we can act like it's friday um
but i really want to check in and let
you know that i really do feel like i've
turned a corner here like it's like it's
clicking into place here and i'm just so
excited about it um i've actually been
sleeping really well
since like after this whole wedding
thing i guess that was like a big weight
on my shoulders it was a good weight it
was something i was excited about but i
was also clearly very anxious about and
i felt like i put in i was putting a lot
of pressure on myself to make it perfect
for myself and to be perfect and for my
anxiety to be perfect and my insomnia to
be perfect and obviously it wasn't at
that point and as a result um
you know like it wouldn't have gone well
even if i was able to go like i probably
would have had a hard time dealing with
my anxiety in that scenario but since
then i've only been taking the trasidone
and the uh propranolol at night to sleep
and i usually am finding now that i wake
up once in the night usually at like 1am
to pee
and i just take a couple milligrams like
one or two
sprays of melatonin and i fall back
asleep which is absolutely insane and
then i just wake up when my kids wake me
up which you know for the longest time i
was waking up well before them and then
just basically like laying in bed until
they woke me up it was like so
depressing because like god i would have
loved that time to just rest but
interestingly one of the side effects i
have found in this process aside from my
nails still growing
look at that look at that regrowth i got
to deal with i am not mad about it
yes yes yes okay is i actually don't
feel the urge to pee as much and i
always knew that my nighttime being was
an anxiety thing and i've described this
to you guys before where it's kind of
like i'm thinking why don't p do i not
need to pee do i need to pee do i not
need to pee over and over and over again
and that obviously keeps me up at night
but i've realized that maybe my like
need to pee all the time in the day even
as well is also an anxiety thing um i
know whenever i am out with my husband
if we're walking if we're traveling if
we're walking around i can literally
only go like 30 minutes without feeling
i need to pee again not like oh my god
i'm gonna pee my pants but like it's
enough to distract me and make me in a
bad mood and my husband always can call
it he's like you need to pee don't you
because you're not talking very much
that's how it always is and so i've been
noticing the last
couple times i've just like gone on
walks like hour long walks there and
back not peed once and not even like
rush to pee when i get home so something
must be happening in my body to allow
myself to kind of relax some of those
like relax my pelvic floor a little bit
better don't ask me i haven't thought
through the physio physiology of this
but i just know that something is
working and it's not just up here it's
like a whole body transformation but
anyways my little one oh woke me up this
morning early at 4 30 which is not
normal um because he just needed a
little cuddle and he went back to bed i
gave him a little pat fat back into bed
and when i went back to bed it was 4 30
i was like okay he's probably like gonna
be up for real season 30 minutes or
whatever so i just laid in bed and i
looked at my phone for a few minutes and
i had this like overwhelming excitement
just for life for this day i was like
i'm excited because it's friday
[Music]
i'm excited for the work i have to do
today which is like i've got to film a
video i've got a call with my team about
a really exciting project i have to look
at some scripts for another very
important and exciting project um and
it's my son's graduation from pre-k and
i can't wait to like clap him out of
school and take him to the grocery store
because he was excited and go to like
the farm on the weekend and do father's
day stuff with our families like i was
just going through all the amazing
things that i'm going to get to do in
the next little while and how grateful i
was about them and how excited i was for
them and i haven't felt that kind of
excitement buzz in a really really long
time my headspace over the last two
years has been like yeah i'm looking
forward to fall because maybe my kids
will be like more my kid will be more
verbal and it'll be easier i'm looking
forward to next year when my kids are in
school i'm looking forward to
this stage of motherhood and i was
having a really hard time just like
living in the now and enjoying the nail
because i was always just hoping that
something in the future would make it
better for me and
yeah so i guess i'm like so excited
because i think
i'd always hear my friends and like
family and stuff like that who've been
on antidepressants be like
it's changed my life i've seen in so
many like forums and facebook groups oh
this drug and so many from you guys too
so many of you guys left me messages and
dms and comments being like you know i
took this drug and it changed my life it
was so nice to see those things i mean
thank you guys all so much for all the
amazing comments you sent me but at the
same time it made me so self-conscious
like it's not changing my life like is
that anything gonna help me and
now i'm kind of being like i feel like
i'm starting to get it maybe this is
going to change my life maybe this is
actively changing my life
so yeah i'm feeling so optimistic
about the day
about the week about life about this
drug and it feels really good and to
celebrate i'm gonna go get my hair blown
out because it always makes me feel
extra extra good to have nice fresh
softly washed and dried hair
so i'm going to do that oh my gosh it is
so hot outside i feel like i just washed
my hair and it's already like greasiest
but i don't care i've got such exciting
news to share one i am sleeping
so in the past week i literally have
slept through the night no joke i have
not even woken up to pee once that
happened like two different nights which
i don't think has happened for years in
my life like literally probably like
since childhood and in the day i'm just
like feeling so full of life i don't
know if it's because i'm sleeping like
it's hard to know i was like what comes
first the chicken or the egg but i feel
super optimistic i feel really happy i
feel just excited about life and like
every morning i get up and even though
i'm busy i'm like i want to get dressed
i want to put makeup on i want to
straighten my hair and this is something
that i really haven't felt for the past
two years in the pandemic like my
husband will come up to me in the
bathroom being like where are you going
today or like what are you doing tonight
you have an important meeting or like an
important interview and i'm just like
nope i'm just hanging around the house
and i just want to feel like myself
again and get out of just wearing like
my sports bra and a robe and putting
real clothes on revolutionary i know
tried to start a revolution but didn't
print enough pamphlets so hardly anyone
turned up except for my mum and her
boyfriend it's the little things today i
was feeling so good so i just went out
for a little walk um i stopped by
sephora i got myself a new lip color
shall we try it on we shall i have a
shopping problem
this is pretty it's fun for summer
love it and more exciting
i went to the liquor store
i just saw it on the way home and i was
like i'mma go in there because it's a
wednesday night and
i could enjoy some wine today so i
picked up my favorite inexpensive pinot
grigio if you're looking for a cheap and
cheerful option
this is the one and i love pinot grigio
it's my grape but other really
interesting discoveries is that
my digestion seems to be a lot better
like my bloating just seems to have
significantly gone down and i'm taking a
lot more risks with like foods that
would ordinarily cause me to bloat so
over the past week or two i've been
craving salad because it's so hot
outside and normally i would avoid
having like large meal salads because i
would feel like i swallowed an entire
balloon but
this week i haven't felt that i've been
able to eat a whole salad as a meal even
and feel really good afterwards so
that's what i'm doing right now i'm
chopping up some vegetables because i
want salad for dinner because it is 35
degrees outside and i can't imagine
cooking anything hot but yeah it's
amazing how interconnected the brain and
the gut is and given how few side
effects i've experienced on this
antidepressant i don't know maybe there
are some merits to this genetics test
that i took if for no other reason than
the fact that it just gave me the
confidence to go in this without a lot
of additional anxiety about the process
even though let's be real i was still
pretty anxious but there's us so i don't
know if you guys have noticed but i'm
doing more vlogging content kind of like
this and i've got my team here more
often and it's partially because that's
the kind of stuff that you guys have
been asking me for and also because it's
just been really good for me to have my
team over be working with other humans
seeing other adults and not just my
children screaming at me all day um and
just like getting out of the house and
having a little bit more fun and i feel
like i'm finally in a good place
mentally where i'm like able to do that
and excited to do that so yeah i'm
feeling good hi guys
all right let's get back to work
well
funny update on
the kind of weight gain side effect
situation i'm sure a lot of you guys are
still wondering about i haven't weighed
myself um nor do i plan on it um but one
of the best pieces of evidence that i
have right now that this whole thing is
working for me
is that i've been able to switch up my
bedtime snack routine so this is such a
trivial sounding stressor for me
but if you guys recall um from maybe my
last update or the one before i was
having these episodes where i would wake
up in the middle of the night ravenous
and starving and because of that i was
really stressed and anxious about waking
up in the middle of the night and being
hungry and disrupting my sleep so i was
having these massive bedtime snacks it
was annoying a binge it was very much
not chaotic i would literally have like
a bowl of protein oats with like lots of
berries and higher fiber cereal on top
and i would have a couple like wraps
with some peanut butter and berries on
top things that i know are like hunger
crushing combos to keep me full but even
if i was like super full from dinner or
just like didn't feel like having a
really big snack i would be scared not
to because i was worried about waking up
hungry and i would like sometimes test
this possibility and have something else
or have something lighter and
i would in fact wake up hungry which is
not good because the data i was
collecting was just like reinforcing my
fear but
suddenly i feel kind of unfazed by that
possibility like just kind of blase
about it so if i just feel like having
like a popsicle after dinner or like
whatever's left in this bag of popcorn i
feel calm about that i feel good about
that decision it's gonna be okay and the
other night i did just have a popsicle
and i don't even know some jerky like
not a huge snack because i was full i
didn't want anything else and i did in
fact wake up in the morning pretty
hungry but i was just like cool data
collected next time i'm gonna need more
snack it's not the end of the world so
not sleeping perfectly just doesn't feel
like it's the end of the world which is
unbelievably freeing so while the
question
like a few months ago was am i going to
gain weight now the question is more
like am i going to lose weight now that
i'm eating more aligned with my actual
hunger cues and not just eating out of
fear that i might get hungry in the
middle of the night and it melts up my
sleep and who knows maybe i will
unconsciously just shift those night
calories to like more morning calories
and it'll all come out in the wash and
that's the amazing thing about bodies
when you're eating intuitively is like
your body kind of has your back and it
wants to maintain the same kind of
setpoint range weight but yeah
we shall see until then
popcorn
[Music]
i clearly spoke too soon
um
if my family wasn't sleeping right now i
would probably lose my
and have a temper tantrum right here
have a good screen but i'm also just so
tired i can't
i feel like i just told you guys how
great my life is feeling and then out of
nowhere
the past two nights i've woken up at 2
a.m
and not being able to get back to sleep
and i just took a ton of drugs i don't
know why because i'm not going to sleep
now and basically laying in bed thinking
like should i take more should i take
less should i have taken that oh my god
now i'm gonna be tired and i have taken
all these drugs and i'm still not gonna
sleep i've gotta film all day and then
i'm it's friday i'm not gonna have a fun
night i'm not gonna have a good weekend
i've got so much my plate blah blah blah
blah that's what my brain sounds like
and you guys are probably thinking do
you have adhd
my doctor doesn't think i have adhd but
we are gonna probably do a screening at
some point um i also don't actually
think i have adhd i just think i have
pretty severe anxiety and
we're coming into a
crazy busy week this week has been so
hectic with filming pretty much every
single day and next week i'm off to new
york for a very important shoot so i'm
feeling
a lot of pressure
and
it usually
seems to weigh on me when i'm trying to
get some rest all right that's my
retainer
so
i'm hungry too which is not good because
the first couple nights i was really
trying to make that effort to
change up
you know and eat how much i felt like i
wanted to eat last night i was like okay
because the night before i was so hungry
i was like i'm was clearly just not
eating enough before bed so i went back
to having a big snack and i felt like so
full when i went to bed um
and i still feel hungry right now so i'm
gonna say that's psychological
but who knows i just feel a little lost
right now i feel a little lost in my
body i feel a little
unsure of
how i can never trust it again and
that's rough that's like a really funny
feeling so i have a lot of empathy for
you guys who
often feel like
you can't trust yourself right now my
body feels like it's failing me